bonjour et bienvenue dans filco
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale on commence tout de
suite avec les grandes lignes de cette
émission les soldes divivers ont débuté
hier nous suivrons ce lancement dans un
magasin de Mor
repas pour sa première visite officielle
en 2014 le Premier ministre s'est rendu
au château de Versailles le thème
aborderé le droit des
femmes et puis nous retrouvons Axel et
Maria deux entrepreneurs qui tentent de
lancer leur entreprise après avoir monté
leur projet ils cherchent aujourd'hui à
trouver des financements la suite de
leur de projets dans le dossier de la
semaine et puis nous parlerons de la
hausse de la TVA pour les commerçants et
les artisans nous recevons sur ce
plateau Thierry laurau bonsoir vous êtes
vice-président de la Chambre de métier
et de l'artisanat on vous retrouve dans
un instant et on passe avant cela à
l'actualité économique de la semaine
je vous le disais dans les titres le
Premier ministre Jean-Marc HRO s'est
rendu ce lundi au château de Versailles
une visite sur le thème de la parité
professionnelle et l'occasion de
dévoiler sa feuille de route pour le
droit des femmes en 2014 un reportage
réalisé avec Jonathan
villman c'est à Versailles que le
premier ministre a choisi de faire sa
première visite officielle de l'année
plus précisément sur un chantier de
restauration du château lundi il y a
rencontré ces femmes qui ont choisi de
faire carrière dans le BTP un secteur
plutôt masculin Corine et chef d'équipe
traceur elle dirige C homme un bel
exemple de mixité que cherche à
valoriser le gouvernement toutes les
expériences que j'ai pour faire de
visite de terrain montre dans les
centres de formation dans les
entreprises que lorsqu'il y a un déclic
lorsqu'on favorise qu'on fait découvrir
les métiers alors les femmes y trouvent
leur place et l'entreprise y trouve
aussi son compte et c'est la société
tout entière qui progresse l'égalité
hommes-femmes une des priorités
affichées du gouvernement après la
parité politique en 2013 place à la
parité professionnelle le Premier
ministre a annoncé des objectifs
ambitieux le premier atteindre d'ici
2025 un taux d'emploi identique pour les
hommes et les femmes il reste
aujourd'hui plus de 9 points d'écart et
pour cela il compte faciliter l'accès au
travail pour les maires et bien nous
nous développons les modes de garde nous
faisons en sorte que par exemple les
femmes qui prennent un congé parental
soit accompagné au retour du congé
parental pour éviter qu'elles soit
placardisé à leur retour nous faisons en
sorte que les femmes après une longue
interruption à s'occuper de leurs
enfants puissent être accompagné dans la
reconversion professionnel nous les
soutenons pour développer une
entreprise deuxième objectif obtenir de
la mixité dans un tiers des métiers 10
secteurs clés sont visés de la petite
enfance à la sécurité civile Corine y
contribue déjà selon elle il faut savoir
faire bouger les choses je suis
constamment sur le chantier alors il
faut savoir s'imposer et avoir un
caractère quoi sinon les hommes ils V
marche dessus après l'entreprise qui
l'emploie fait figure de bon élève elle
a obtenu dès 2006 le label Égalité mais
le secteur du bâtiment est encore à la
traain seul 1,6 % des ouvriers sont des
femmes la loi antiamazone a été votée
hier au Sénat vise à protéger les
librairies indépendantes elles sont près
de 3000 en France et souffrent
actuellement de la concurrence des
vendeurs en ligne de livres papier alors
que le prix du livre est censé être
unique depuis 1980 ces ces vendeurs
pardon cumulent souvent en gratuité des
fraisports et Rabé autorisé de 5 % cette
nouvelle loi antiamazon du nom du
principal vendeur en ligne interdit
désormais ce cumule de réduction de quoi
contenter les libraires français tels
que le responsable des librairies du
pavé on l'écoute c'est une très très
bonne chose c'est une loi sur en effet
une commerce le commerce loyal puisque
les pratiques d'amazone sont souvent des
pratiques à la limite de la légalité que
ce soit là sur les frais de port où en
effet la France est un des rares pays où
ils offraent des frais de port et on
voit bien lorsqu'on étudie dans le
détail que ils offrent les frais de port
dans les pays où ils veulent obtenir des
parts de marché les plus importants et
dès qu'ils ont départ de marché
important et ben il supprime les
gratuités des frais de port donc là ça
nous met un concurrence
égale avec
Amazon et c'est une très bonne la
meilleure prveé c'est que cette loi a
été votée à l'unanimité proposée par
l'opposition accepté par le Gouvernement
et voté à l'unanimité et la vente en
ligne équivaut aujourd'hui à 17 % départ
de marché et sur ce secteur précis
Amazon accumule 80 % du
trafic premier jour de solld de ce
mercredi nous nous sommes rendus à
l'ouverture d'un supermarché à morepa
les clients ont bien entendu répondu
présent mais l'enseigne s'attend à une
baisse de la fréquentation des images
d'odim
moine dans ce supermarché les salariés
ont passé une partie de la nuit à
étiqueter et à placer les produits à
quelques minutes de l'ouverture on
finalise les rayonnages tout doit être
prêt pour l'arrivée des clients 8h30 le
rideau se lève derrière une centaine de
personnes bien décidées à profiter des
soldes premier arrivé premier service
les meilleur affaires c'est le premier
jour c'est parmi les premières heures
même le magasin propose des réductions à
jusqu'à - 70 % de quoi faire des
affaires et là à chacun sa technique il
y a ceux qui fouillent et ceux qui ont
bien préparé leurs achats j'ai fait mon
repérage et j'espère que je vais trouver
mon bonheur dans tous les cas les cadis
se remplissent vite même si cette année
l'enseigne prévoi une baisse de la
fréquentation c'est vrai que le
l'élasticité moins importante quand même
que ce qu'on pouvait connaître il y a il
y a quelques années parce que bah oui il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de de promotions
et d'opération tout au long de l'année
donc c'est vrai que ça dilue quand même
un petit peu un petit peu l'impact des
des soldes malgré tout il reste quand
même un delta qui qui est non
négligeable les magasins de vêtements
plus particulièrement ont lancé des
ventes privées des soldes avant les sold
c'est tout de même dans le textile que
ce supermarché compte faire son plus
gros chiffre d'affaires en règle
générale les ventes du rayon vêtement
atteignent 100000 € le premier jour
ayant 5 semaines de soldes de 10 à 12 %
du chiffre d'affaires annuel malgré la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat 62 % des
Français devraient dépenser plus de 100
€ pour les soldes une donnée confirmée
par les clients de ce magasin si
j'arrive à tout trouver aux alentours de
500 600 € 300
€ il reste jusqu'au 11 février pour
profiter des soldes dans ce magasin si
les collections passées ne sont pas
écoulées d'ici là une partie du stock
sera donné à des
associations université de Saint-Quentin
en proche de la cessation de paiements
c'est ce que vous nous vous indiquions
fin 2013 l'État a aidé à combler le
déficit de plus de 4 millions d'euros
pour cette nouvelle année 2014 le vote
du budget se tiendra le 14 janvier il
sera déficitaire mais l'État a de
nouveau assuré l'université de son
soutien le budget devrait revenir à
l'équilibre d'ici
2016 et en ce début d'année vous avez
certainement du goûter la galette des
rois à l'origine elle célèbre
l'épiphanie le 6 janvier aujourd'hui
elle est devenue une vraie tradition et
bien entendu une source de revenus
importante pour les boulangers
pâtissiers pour cette enseigne que vous
voyez à l'image à Chevreuse ce début
d'année représente 15 % du chiffre
d'affaires un moment à ne pas rater pour
se démarquer on mise surtout sur la
fabrication traditionnelle la grande
surface cherche un prix nous on cherche
la qualité on cherche pas un prix les
fèves soit on les personnalise on les a
déjà fait ou soit effectivement on
essaie d'avoir des fèves haut de gamme
pour se démarquer de la concurrence quoi
et de la grande distribution ça dépend
des les années en ce moment
effectivement on est plutôt sur une
période de baisse alors on peut varier
de 750 pièces à 1500
pièces et en France le prix moyen en
mètre carré pour l'immobilier recule de
1,8 % sur 1 an après avoir déjà baissé
de 1,9 % en 2012 il s'établit désormais
à 2568 € d'après la dernière étude sur
l'immobilier ancien publié par Century
21 mais dans les evelines les prix
grimpent le prix moyen en mètre carré
s'établi à 3504 € soit une évolution de
plus de 2 % comme vous allez pouvoir le
voir sur ce tableau qui
s'affiche nous ne l'avons pas petite
petit souci technique cela concerne
principalement en tout cas les
appartements et surtout les achats à
titre de placement qui en paâtissent
c'est maintenant l'heure de
l'entretien quelle conséquence aura la
hausse de la TVA sur les commerçants et
les artisans et du coup sur les
consommateurs notre invité va pouvoir
nous éclairer nous REC nous recevons
pardon Thierry Lauro bonsoir vous êtes
vice-président de la Chambre de Métiers
l'artisanat alors les taux de TVA ont
été modifiés au 1er janvier cela fait
suite à l'OL de finan de 2012 alors dans
le détail le taux intermédiaire donc qui
concerne principalement l'artisanat mais
aussi les transports et le relevé de 7 à
10 % plus 3 points alors cela vous
concerne dans une moindre mesure mais le
taux normal passe de 19,6 à 20 et le
taux de TVA réduit lui ne bouge pas 5,5
mais compte désormais entre autres les
entrées de cinéma ou les spectacles
vivants alors ce passage de 7 à 10 %
qu'est-ce que ça va changer disons sur
cette hausse sur quoi va être va-être
va-être elle répercutée je vais y
arriver alors il y a plusieurs impacts
le premier ça va être bien sûr une
baisse de pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs hein c'est évident à
partir du moment où les prix augmentent
de de 3 % sur une grande partie de des
produits euh ça c'est le côté
consommateur qui aujourd'hui lui a un
budget qui est pas extensible il n'est
plus extensible donc de toute façon il
va continuer à consommer les sommes dont
il dispose il a plus de de marge de main
d'œuvre c'est terminé donc ça veut dire
que à un moment donné où il achètera
moins de produit ou bien il achètera de
moins bonne qualité mais voilà il pourra
pas rajouter ce montant là donc après au
niveau de de l'artisanat des artisans
deux écoles ou bien euh dire bah on
applique strictement l'augmentation de
TVA et on augmente les prix faut savoir
quand même qu'en début d'année on subit
aussi les hausses de matières premières
donc ça veut dire voilà une augmentation
qui est pas que de 3 % qui va être plus
importante que ça et donc un prix qui va
bouger de façon sensible deuxième école
c'est ce que certains commerçants essaye
de faire de dire ben tant pis on on
absorbe cette augmentation sachant que
cette absorption d'augmentation ation
elle va se répercuter sur le chiffre
d'affaires sur le bénéfice et ainsi de
suite et sur la rémunération peut-être
de de l'entrepreneur du gérant de
l'artisan alors au niveau de l'artisanat
il y a justement eu pas mal de de
d'appel d'appel du P on va dire envers
le gouvernement vous indiquez que
beaucoup d'entreprises sont dans le
rouge je crois que vous avez quelques
données des tribunaux de commerce bah
effectivement sur le dernier trimestre
les chiffres qui nous sont remontés des
des tribunaux de commerce
c'est dans l'artisanat tout secteur
confondu c'est la disparition de six
entreprises toutes les heures donc c'est
c'est un chiffre assez impressionnant ch
impressionnant il faut relativiser il y
a aussi des
créations en parallèle mais au final
c'est des jeunes qui remplacent voilà le
problème c'est vieilles et les anciennes
plus grosses entreprises ce que ce qu'on
constate c'est que ce sont des
entreprises qui avait effectivement 10
15 20 ans d'existence avec un nombre de
salariés conséquent qu qui disparaissent
et que les entreprises qui se créent
elles bah sont des entreprises jeunes
donc on sait très bien qui certaines ne
vont pas se péréniser et souvent avec un
nombre de salariés très faible donc un
impact sur le chômage forcément dans le
secteur de la restauration alors le cas
est un peu particulier puisque à la base
ce secteur était autonormal à 19,6 % ils
ont obtenu un tau réduit en 2009 il a
augmenté depuis donc il passe également
de 7 à 10 % on avait reproché au
restaurateurs de ne pas avoir répercuté
la la baisse de la TVA en 2009 je
propose d'écouter la réaction du
président de la Confédération des
restaurateurs indépendants des
ivelin nous avons quand même pour le
personnel augmenté les salaires nous
avons une prime TVA que nous versons à
nos personnels chaque mois de juillet
depuis 2009 nous avons également mis en
place une mutuelle pour la totalité de
nos salariés ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant dans ce métier et beaucoup d'entre
nous ont investi dans leurs entreprises
donc là maintenant le taux de TVA à 10
points euh c'est insupportable nous
aurions préféré rester au taux de TVA à
7 qui permettait quand même aux
restaurateur de pouvoir après avoir
absorbé ça dans leur marge ne pas
augmenter leur prix là maintenant
malheureusement en 2014 nous sommes
obligés pour la plupart d'entre nous de
répercuter cette hausse de TVA il va
bien falloir à un moment donné que
les gouvernant se rendent compte que la
prise des taxes des impôts de toute
nature sur les prix doit s'inverser
alors on veut inverser la courbe du
chômage c'est normal il faut aussi
inverser la courbe des prix alors de
grandes difficultés également pour les
restaurateurs sur cette critique de de
la baisse de la TVA qui n'a pas été
répercutée sur les restaurateurs est-ce
que ce n'est pas justement le risque
finalement dans l'artisanat plus
largement c'est que on peut pas on peut
pas faire les deux c'est on peut pas
répercuter sur le prix de vente la
baisse de la TVA et en même temps
augmenter les salaires augmenter voilà
donner des primes comme l'expliquait
monsieur voilà on peut pas il faut faire
un choix à un moment les lesmarches sont
pas suffisantes pour qu'on puisse
contenter tout le monde travailler sur
les deux tableaux alors vous travaillez
vous-même dans dans le bâtiment donc
dans ce secteur il y a eu quelques
cadeaux entre guillemets la construction
et la rénovation de logements sociaux
notamment passe auutau réduit de 5,5
tout comme la rénovation énergétique
est-ce que ça peut faciliter les choses
alors dans l'artisanat en ce qui
concerne les logements sociaux
peu c'est un secteur qui qui est très
peu pénétré par les les artisans sont
souvent des rénovations lourdes donc ce
sont des
entrepris r conséquente et sur la
rénovation énergétique oui mais ça
concerne une frange très faible de
l'activité du
bâtiment beaucoup de de professions ne
sont pas impactées et celles qui seront
concerné c'est pas 100 % de leur
activité ça va être quelques postes dans
dans leur activité donc ce que vous
m'indiquiez ce qui est compliqué c'est
pour l'instant donc ça concerne les
travaux de rénovation énergétique et les
travaux induits pour l'instant vous
n'avez pas encore les papiers c'est
normalement au 1er janvier mais vous
n'avez pas reçu encore les papiers de
gouvernement pour mettre cela en place
la question qu'on se pose c'est ça que
sont les travaux induits jusqu'où
vont-ils jusqu'où peut-on aller comment
va interpréter ça l'état comment
allons-nous l'interpréter comment le
client va l'interpréter ça va être
difficile à mettre en œuvre on devrait
avoir cette réponse très bientôt ben
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'être venu
sur notre plateau et on passe au dossier
de la
semaine souvenez-vous il y a de mois
nous vous parlions d'Axelle Courson et
Maria gaffnet deux entrepreneurs qui
tentent de lancer leur société à
sa-quenttin en Yveline l'un veut
commercialiser une bière locale l'autre
ouvrir une crêperie que deviennent-il je
vous propose de le découvrir dans ce
dossier de la semaine réalisé avec
Elodie
moine on prend du mal
on met dans le
réservoir concasser des grains de malt
la première étape pour obtenir de la
bière Axel s'est pris de passion pour le
brassage il y a maintenant 1 an au point
de vouloir en faire son métier son
projet avance mais pour l'instant il
doit se contenter de sa cuisine pour
brasser dans cette marmite Malte et haut
Axel espère bientôt acquérir du matériel
professionnel tout ça ça sera des cuves
automatisé avec des pompes avec des ça
va accélérer beaucoup le processus quoi
pour le moment tout est fait à la main
filtrer le jus de Malte puis le refaire
bouillir avec le houblon laisser reposer
en ajoutant les levure dernière étape
sucrée et embouteillé ça va être une
bière qui va être assez fraîche et ouais
avec des notes un peu
floral floral ou végétal après une
formation en création d'entreprise et en
brassage cet été il est allé
dernièrement rendre visite à quelques
concurrents notamment la semaine
dernière je suis allé à Bougival dans
une brass qui s'appelle la petite sœur
donc pour discuter avec eux donc c'est
deux personnes qui sont installé il y a
un an et qui vraiment ont vécu ce vivent
là Axel a reçu un accueil plutôt positif
dans le département mais pour vivre son
rêve et commercialiser sa bière locale
ce passionné doit réunir les fonds
nécessaires ce jeune entrepreneur a
postulé pour le prénacre un prêtdonneur
réservé aux chômeurs ainsi qu'à un
emprunt auprès de la plateforme Eveline
initiative c'est vraiment les deux
éléments principaux qui vont
conditionner la suite et qui sont qui
qui sont vraiment structurants pour pour
la suite parce que si j'ai les aides
j'obtiens les prêts bancaires si j'ai
les prêts bancaires je peux signer le
local je peux commander le matériel et
je peux lancer l'activité si je les ai
pas dans ce cas-là bah je je pense que
le projet va être assez compromis pour
le prénacre il aura la réponse dans
quelques heures je suis vraiment très
très très stressé j'ai hâte j'ai hâte
qui m'appelle qui m'envoie un message ou
quoi pour me dire déjà pour aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est bien nous retrouvons
Axel à la Maison de l'Entreprise prise
de Saint-Quentin en yeline le lendemain
bonne nouvelle il a obtenu le prénacre
reste maintenant à convaincre le jury
d'iveline initiative il attend son tour
en compagnie de Maria son amie qui ouvre
une crêperie elle aussi cherche des
fonds et on essaie de fonctionner en
binô comme nos projets sont un peu
complémentaires on essaie de les mettre
en avant chacun et ça nous fait une
force d'être à deux puis surtout au
moment de la dégustation elleelle peut
ramener à manger moi je ramène à boire
ça fonctionne pas mal il est temps pour
Axel de passer devant le jury chef
d'entreprise et responsable
institutionnel l'attendent je vous cède
la parole nous sommes tous
toutou Axel a 15 minutes pour présenter
son projet l'enjeu est de taille et son
stress
palpable parti de mes études sur sur mon
et c'est
notamment notamment au lycée que j'ai
rencontré mon ami avec qui je me suis
Axel demande un prêt de 15000 € de quoi
se lancer mais surtout débloquer sont
prébancaire le jury étudie son business
plan déguste puis délibère vient le
temps du verdict on va pas vous faire
plus longtemps nous avons délibéré et le
comité a décidé de soutenir votre projet
Axel sort de la pièce soulagé et
ravi bien je change de VI c'est
bon
pare ça marche ouais tu me laissesièand
VO je suis déjà très très très très
contente pour Axel je suis vraiment très
très heureuse et à moi maintenant Maria
a de son côté demandé 25000 € mais
depuis peu son associé s'est retiré un
revirement qui risque de fragiliser son
projet aux yeux du jury Maria réussi
tout de même une belle prestation à
l'auditoire maintenant de
trancherot
comp son parcours estz
chatique quand elle retourne dans la
salle la chef entreprise redoute le pire
le comité a délibéré il a décidé de vous
suivre dans votre projet vous soutenir
dans votre projet pour elle aussi les
fonds sont débloqués son projet peut
pleinement démarrer ils ont cru à mon
projet ils ont adoré laané au crépris
qu'est-ce que voulez que je dise d'autre
je suis heureuse mon projet il avance et
il démarre il y va et il all laiss
d'abord démarrer la rénovation du
restaurant cette banque courtoise a
racheté cette ancienne crêperie à
quelques de chez elle elle retrouve
aujourd'hui Nicolas en charge des
travaux il faut aujourd'hui tout
reconstruire mais Maria s'y voit déjà
ici c'est la salle donc la salle elle va
elle fait tout ça ici et ici il y aura
des banquettes en vraie fonceuse elle a
lancé les travaux il y a quelques jours
sans même savoir si le prénacre lui
avait été donné un Paris risqué je avoué
que j'ai eu un coup de flip j'ai eu peur
aujourd'hui avec Eveline active j'ai eu
peur parce que je me suis
et si et si il refusait me refuser le
truc qu'est-ce que je fais quoi B bon si
j'ai pris le risque ok je me suis bien
amusé c'est bien c'est bon mais non là
ça continue ça continue c'est
merveilleux les travaux devraient se
terminer d'ici fin février début mars
Axel a choisi la même ville pour
s'implanter leur société seront voisines
on est ami d'abord on est voisin aussi
donc quand quand il a fait une démarche
et cetera donc il va il va me prévenir
de ce qu'il a fait et comment il faut le
faire et cetera mais aussi des embuches
qu'on peut avoir c'est moi qui vais à la
mairie je connais plus la mairie de lui
en cours que lui donc je vais lui dire
qu la démarche comment est la personne
comment tu l'abordes et ceci cela il
viennent régulièrement à la maison euh
pour parler pour machin et qu'est-ce que
tu penses de ça et on discute oui c'est
plus qu'un copain de promo quoi son ami
Axel a déniché un local au Clos du
Moulin avant il vient tout juste de
signer le contrat et revient visiter les
lieux avec sa compagne Doris ça y est
j'ai les clés ouais elles sont là c'est
bon c'est chez moi son chez lui le voici
un grand hangar vide pour le moment le
matériel de brassage ne devrait arriver
que dans quelques mois en attendant il
faut faire preuve d'imagination donc les
clients ils vont arriver ils vont
arriver par ici ils vont directement
avoir une visuelle sur cet espace ici
qui sera la salle de production donc là
en fait sur ce mur là on aura des des
cuves donc qui vont monter jusqu'à 3 m
on aura 4 C cuves
ici on aura toutes les toute la partie
brassage donc chauffe ensuite pourir se
diriger par ici donc là ça sera l'espace
dégustation Axel souhaite que ses
clients découvrent la fabrication de la
bière les différentes salles seront donc
vitrées à l'étage il installera ses
bureaux il reste encore quelques
finitions avant l'arrivée du matériel on
va le personnaliser un petit peu on on
va faire ça au fur à mesure avec Doris
on va faire ça Doris n'y pas pour rien
dans ce projet assez atypique c'estit
elle qui lui a offert il y a un an son
premier kit de brassage quand il lui a
annoncé vouloir en faire son métier cela
ne l'a pas tant étonné moi j'ai trouvé
ça super parce que bah il était dans un
contexte professionnel où bah ce qu'il
faisait ça ça lui plaisait pas trop
enfin il y avait des bons côtés et des
mauvais côtés mais au final il était pas
vraiment épanoui donc le fait qu'il
veille monter son affaire qu'il veille
brasser sa propre bière je me suis dit
s'il a trouvé sa voix ben tant mieux
quoi il faut qu' il faut qu'il se lance
il faut
fa qu'il le fasse quoi non c'est tout à
fait ça c'est
c'est grâce à elle quoi un petit peu
Doris compte prendre le statut de
conjoint collaborateur cela lui
permettra de donner un coup de main à
Axel durant son temps libre déjà j'ai
envie de l'aider et puis j'ai envie de
faire partie de l'aventure aussi quoi
une aventure qui ne fait que
démarrer dans l'agenda on notera une
journée d'information à la Cité des
Métiers à trappe mercredi 15 janvier de
10h à 17h il s'agit d'un atelier pour
valoriser une offre de compétenence pour
les 45 ans et plus c'est organisé par le
club face vous retrouvez donc les
indications à
l'écran c'est la fin de ce filcho merci
de nous avoir suivi avant de se quitter
je vous propose d'écouter les souhaits
d'habitants de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
des vœux de 2014 mais dans le secteur
économique je souhaiterais que le
chômage
surt et puis surtout à partir de là ça
devrait aller mieux
je les considération environnemental
soit davantage prise en compte que soit
au niveau local ou national on doit
attendre jusqu'à mois de mars avril pour
les élections j'aimerais bien qu'il y
ait beaucoup moins de chômage et que les
jeunes trouvent du boulot beaucoup de
travail parce ce moment cherche du
travail j'ai du mal à trouver j'aimerais
bien être augmenté encore pouvoir
m'acheter plein de vêtements que le coût
de la vie diminue parce qu' il augmente
il augmente énormément et c'est vrai que
ça devient de plus en plus plus en plus
compliqué bah de faire des sorties c'est
très compliqué les jeunes plutôt les
jeunes il arrivent à trouver un boulot
avec leur bac déjà voilà parce queils
ont leur bac ils ont des diplômes et ils
travaillent pas les impôts
liminuent peut-être des augmentations de
salaire n'est-ce pas comme tout le monde
j'imagine je suis pas le
seul